c'est la grande nouveauté des élections
départementales pour la première fois
les électeurs ne voteront pas pour un ou
une candidate mais pour un binôme hommes
femmes un objectif enfin atteint pour
lequel s'est battu le réseau elle aussi
un réseau pluraliste d'associations de
femmes qui militent pour la parité dans
toutes les instances élues depuis sa
création en 1992 c'est une véritable
révolution pour la première fois il y
aura une assemblée avec 50 % 25 % de
femmes ce qui veut dire qu'il va y avoir
un grand renouvellement d'ailleurs c'est
prouver puisque d'après les statistiques
dans les binômes qui se sont formés
75 78 % des binômes ce sont des
personnes qui ne sont pas sortante exit
le scrutin uninominal
voici venu le temps du scrutin binominal
en france de 13 9 % de femmes dans les
conseils généraux actuels la proportion
passera donc directement à 50% dans les
nouvelles assemblées dans le département
des yvelines la tendance actuelle est à
peu près la même qu'au niveau national
la situation est assez catastrophique
car sur les 39 cantons nous n'avons que
six femmes qui sont conseillères
générales ce qui représente 15% et parmi
les vice-présidents
il y à 0 femmes avec le redécoupage il y
aura donc vingt-et-une femmes et 21
hommes donc là ça sera vraiment la
parité il y aura trois conseillers
généraux départementaux même de plus
parmi les femmes candidates à ce scrutin
dans les yvelines on compte 5 sortante
les autres viennent pour la plupart
soient des élections municipales soient
de la société civile bien qu'elle
qualifie cette parité de réelles
avancées bien qu'elle qualifie cette
parité de réelles avancées martin et
armait la note tout de même quelques
déséquilibres persistants au niveau des
candidatures sur les affiches par
exemple les hommes seraient mis en avant
et dans les médias dans 90% des cas
l'homme serait citée en premier ce que
l'on craignait et ce que l'on a vu au
niveau des candidatures c'est que les
hommes sortant et les les barons de la
politique locaux c'est un peu con fait
le casting se sont plutôt qu'en fait le
casting se dire qu'ils ont décidé quels
sont les hommes qui allait se
représenter ceux qui sont les nouveaux
cas laisse présenté parmi les hommes et
après ils ont cherché les femmes malgré
des avancées positives il reste donc
encore du chemin à parcourir pour
parvenir à un équilibre parfait